[Applaudissements]
vous allez voir ce que je ne voir dans
l'instant sachez qu'on va retrouver
camille combat j'en ressors là tout de
suite sur des beats il ya michel drucker
qui est notre invité applaudissements
pour lui un ami 6 et nous allons faire
une grande course de vélo car vous le
savez un michel drucker est fan de vélo
ou continuer le vélo michel combes
maintes fois par semaine j'ai fait
beaucoup de vélo mais pas avec ce modèle
là un pas exclu celui-là il est bien sûr
alors nous ne sommes pas que deux pour
cette course il a également le meilleur
grimpeur le richard virenque de l'équipe
s'étoffe un aplanissement pour lui
[Applaudissements]
attention vous nous donner le top on a
tout un parcours et on terminera sur le
plateau attention à ce que c'est parce
que vous êtes faits qui donne le top 3
on allait enfin à leur fin
tu crois syrie qu'est ce que tu crois
mais qu'est ce que tu crois mais qu'est
ce que tu
[Applaudissements]
et je signais perdu ma selle c'est le
seul animateur qui pds naissance elle
oui on a la voiture balai qui va arriver
pour te fasse je demande à tous
[Rires]
demande un contrôle anti doping sur
cyril hanouna
abbas m merci michel week-end
[Applaudissements]